For the grand finale,
we finally come to closures.
Closures are similar to blocks in
Objective C, or lambdas as in Python,
Java and Ruby.
Closures, like functions,
are self-contained blocks of code.
So what's the difference between
a closure and a function?
Well, global functions and
nested functions, which we didn't
have a chance to talk about, but
if you're curious, follow the link
in the instructor's notes.
Anyway, global functions and
nested functions are closures.
But most of the time when a person
refers to a closure in Swift,
they're referring to
a closure expression.
In this lesson, we'll be
focusing on closure expressions.
So what's a closure expression?
A closure expression is an unnamed
self-contained block of code
that can be passed as
an argument to a function.
Closure expressions are unique
in that they're unnamed.
Okay, but
what are closure expressions good for?
Well, this ability to pass
a block of code to a function
makes it easy to specify an action to
be executed sometime in the future.
Let's look at a couple examples.